today's topic I
die in my sleep because I have something
called in more often sleep apnea if you
don't wear what sleep apnea is
essentially when you during your sleep
stop breathing which revolves results in
uh basically because no oxygen is
reaching your brain your brain after a
little bit of toxin signal which then
causes you to have a bit of a shock
moment and you inhale for air thus
retent but you never get any deep form
of sleep because your brain is
constantly going through something
terrible okay and your body as a result
as well that's why I snore really loudly
now I didn't know why I'd sleep around
here for a long time thank God for the
military because all the soldiers who
work besides say hey [__] you something
wrong with you
every time we do Fields exercise like
it's not normal that the enemy always
knows where we at Rough we can't have
you on Earth
because every field exercise is [__]
useless oh my brother is that really
that way are they
over there
bro if y'all heard me sleeping my
snoring is crazy okay it's it's crazy
it's legendary all right really terrible
and the girlfriend at the time this is
like my early 20s she said she was a
nurse she said yo something wrong with
you when you sleep I said what's wrong
you say yo you make the same sound
effect when you sleep that I make when I
suck your dick I said oh my God
something wrong I thought for a second I
was getting my sleep but it turns out I
just got sleep after him okay so I'm
panicking I go to the doctor let's find
out fast material okay I'll go to the
doctor I go to the doctor to find out
and the doctor's like yeah you do have a
problem he's like well he's like we're
gonna do a sleep study but it sounds
like you guys you have a problem what is
it you suck dick
we have discovered that you are okay
you are so naturally gay you are getting
your sleep my friend you decided to suck
the penis while you are sleeping you
have imagined it and you have such it in
reality
yes the devil resides in your soul my
friends you are deviant
they do a sleep study if you're on the
way what a sleep study is essentially
hook yourself up with a bunch of little
nodules all over your body and then once
you go to sleep they keep you at the
hospital overnight or the lab clinic and
then they monitor your sleep patterns
how many times you interrupt your sleep
patterns now if you don't know how sleep
works
not everyone's six hours of sleep is
gonna look the same why do you wake up
intermittently to go take water breaks
or leak breaks
um do you get into a deep sleep maybe
there's a condition that stops you from
getting there or if you have a lot of
interruptions from CW like I do myself
you never get into this state called REM
sleep REM sleep is basically a deep form
of sleep that really uh facilitates uh
the repairing of cells uh the fact that
you feel refreshed in the morning by
getting your energies level back up and
so me from ages like
child to when I was 26 27 okay I never
was getting any REM sleep because every
night I was snoring I didn't have any
way to fix it REM so I think that gets
you in the corner I wake up and the dog
looks on my truck he's like bro you got
some of the worst sleep apnea I've ever
heard I'm like how do I like how is this
possible and he says it's hereditary
often times what ends up happening is a
lot of people inherit it genetically
from their parents and I think it's even
more common amongst black people versus
different groups of people but it's
still very common I think so with that
in mind I'm like all right what are the
treatment options available and he said
listen we have something called a CPAP
machine it's basically something that
gives constant pressurized air to your
system so that all night while you're
sleeping you never have any
interruptions thus getting to sleep I'm
like bruh I'm in my early 20s I don't be
hooked up to some [__] dumb looking
machine every night when I go to bed I
wasn't down for it fast forward next
four or five years after getting out of
the military
um sleep apnea was honestly [__] up
my life in ways I couldn't tell I would
fall asleep on buses all the time I
would fall asleep behind the car which
made me stop driving for a long time
what was the numbers one in 15 Americans
or one in 15 Americans what that are
diagnosed the reason why I say diagnosis
that most a lot I bet you this most
people have sleep apnea don't know they
have sleep I have a case of sleep apnea
okay most people who have sleep do not
know they have it they don't know that
anybody else around them has it they
just think it's snoring or they just
think it's normal to wake up tired or
whatever it is it's not
um I would fall asleep everywhere and it
became an issue for me because even
sleepovers were something I had a hard
time doing because I would feel super
self-conscious about keeping my partner
awake so it's affecting my relationships
it's affecting my ability to just live
every day it was affecting my work
productivity it was affecting my energy
levels I was always drowsy and one day I
just bit the bullet I decided I would
get it it was a weird adjustment at
first having this thing I got the nasal
mask and that's what worked best for me
and
yeah I'll tell you this within like two
three weeks my life [__] changed
I woke up one day
and I actually woke up
my eyes were actually open he woke you
you was woke woke you saw the light walk
in the best you try to find it's such a
bizarre thing because you take it for
granted if you have good sleep you don't
have to worry about it
but when you don't have it you don't
realize what it is to actually have it
on a regular basis so for me I was just
like yo how was I living before this how
was I functioning at all like you know
how many traffic accidents how many
people are dying of early disease like
having bad sleep is a very strong
predictor for Alzheimer's and all other
kinds of end-of-life diseases because of
the fact that you're degenerating your
cells from not getting good quality
sleep so I was just literally just dying
at an exponential rate because the fact
that I wasn't treating this thing that
was given to me by my father right and
whatever answers right so this is mine
here it's definitely been through a lot
this one's actually discontinued because
some of the foam was recalled I took it
apart took out the phone you know what
I'm saying because I'm cheap [__] I got
money but I still don't like spending it
uh so I got this thing right here dream
station ghost little it's portable uh
and it's good I also have another one
that's also very portable in light so if
ever I feel like this one's weird but
there's a bunch of different ones some
larger smaller units so you get what
works for you but this is the machine
yeah there's travel ones there's travel
one that's not one that's one of them I
have one that's even smaller the other
one I have is like this size man we're
not
promoting nothing okay the one I have is
about this size uh and essentially yeah
just this mask right here it's a nasal
mask for me so it works out really well
and all I have to do is go like this all
right it looks crazy again this is why I
didn't want to get it at first right
because I thought it would look so dumb
and I'm like bro yeah you kind of look
like a Teletubby
looking [__]
Luke
who's your daddy
um sound like Darth Vader didn't seem
interesting but once you get used to it
the benefits of having good sleep far
outweigh anything else we going on tour
we come into cities near you we want to
see you [__] face to face where
you at we gonna be doing shows all
summer well this summer we're doing
three shows we're doing Detroit
Pittsburgh and Washington DC but
afterwards we were going to England
we're going to be going all across
America Asia so if you want to get
tickets make sure you guys go to the
website all right put your name so we
can email you as soon as those tickets
come out for your area we won't bombard
you with nothing else okay I promise
um we want to see you guys at the shows
we meet us we have meet and greets we're
gonna have a lot of fun we're gonna do
laughing so it's gonna be a good time uh
but we want to see you guys so the
machine came in really changed my life
and enabled me to be able to sleep
everywhere even sleepovers it doesn't
even matter such a small discrete
doesn't make any noise so I sleep super
well Partners have slept super well so
it's never been an issue for me in a
relationship standpoint and it's just
it's made my life so much easier so much
easier so I'm pretty grateful for it and
I think a lot of you guys watching at
home probably have sleep apnea and don't
know it or do know what to decide not to
get the machine and if I can tell you
anything please get it okay please
invest in it because not sleeping well
will not only kill you much faster but
puts your lives in danger behind the
wheel in a lot of different
circumstances and you deserve good
quality sleep you deserve to feel
refreshed and feel good in the morning
and if you don't invest in this stuff
for some of you guys insurance will
cover it for others
um it could be government handed if you
have to get it even from a private
person do it do it because it honestly
changed my life and it feels good it
feels good to not suck dick when I go to
bed pause
ladies you can suck a dick before you go
to bed that's perfectly fine I'm just
saying gay guys too dudes if everybody
say that's fine too but if you like me
you don't want to be all yourself yeah I
mean don't do it
pause
you know one day
you know one day somebody do that
compilation all the [__] we said and
like in a vacuum is fine but I think if
you guys did a compilation I look super
sauce you you too oh no [__] what's
your man hey hey [__]
hey hey baby I don't even need to say
such [__] for people to think that I say
that I'm says that's what I'm saying
your compilation will just be you
talking
that sleep apnea what do you know about
sleeping you want to say I don't know
when people die I know a couple of
things about sea biting you know I mean
like with your fat you have more chances
of having sleep apnea is that phobic
shut up
um it is what it is you know I mean your
weight is on you so it is what at the
end of the day it is what it is you take
it or you leave it you have more chances
you have more chances but it is what it
is I don't have it I kind of have it
when uh uh I'm sick
when my Airways are blocked and stuff
like that I don't sleep well at all also
if you didn't know what ends up
happening you got sleep apnea is that
your jaw muscles relax and so they
collapse inward thus closing your
Airways and what ends up happening is a
shock from the brain basically forces
the airway forward and then air goes
through but then it happens again
depending on how severe it is but yes
sorry you were saying nothing
REM sleep yeah it's the best absolutely
rapid eye movement
your eyes go like that right and yeah
that's a deep form of sleep that's it
that's it
um yeah so if you guys are watching
please take your health seriously uh if
it helps any of you that's it's my it's
not and it's not just for the Sleep
Batman that's pretty much for anything
for your weight for your your body your
body how you feel I mean you know if
you're obese you should just lose the
weight that's like your best bet because
not needing the machine is probably the
best scenario of all uh but a lot of
sleep apnea at least mine I've had it
since I was like 140 pounds even now 200
I'm chilling it doesn't change how much
sleep apnea I have but it's not because
you're not obese that you cannot haven't
seen back yet no I I would say that vast
majority of Sleepover is not linked to
obesity it's just hereditary yeah but
there's some segment of it that is
definitely a portion of it uh yeah
I think that's pretty much covers most I
want to see yeah so guys if you guys
have any questions leave them in the
comments below for those of you who do
have sleeping if you are treating it I
want to hear from y'all for those who
think they might have it or know someone
close to me might have it let us hear
from you guys as well the end of the day
um information is what saved me I
watched a podcast on with a sleep doctor
and that like opened my brain to realize
like okay this is actually really
serious I should take it seriously so
I'm hoping this information helps you
guys as well uh so that's pretty much
all I have people think like go for it
people people die super young especially
in the black community you know I mean
they die at 40 50. they don't know when
you just die like that no man sometimes
it's the food the sleep apnea not you're
not listening to the signs and stuff
like that so yeah you know what's crazy
it will put a toll on you yeah it's
crazy because my father had it and
everyone's just oh my God he snores
really loud
was like no
nobody even realized it but the dude has
a medical condition it was negatively
impacting himself his whole life and
then it's crazy because I went to my
siblings also have it
none of them are using a machine so
people are just dying much earlier from
not knowing yeah
once you see like the circles around
your eyes are getting dark or you got a
black patch in your neck looks like it's
dirty
check your [__] yeah my eyes used to be
so droopy I used to look like this you
know it's like I was in high school and
my binders had accumulated more Jewel
than ink on the papers
because I spent most of my classes
sleeping
you do suck dick when you sleep that's a
lot of jewels I'm just saying [__] keep
on going
I walked into that once I can't even be
that mad at you because I didn't walk
into that one like this
why are you so much speed when you sleep
all this to say it's just like I just
thought that [__] was normal and it
wasn't
it just it wasn't normal so I don't want
that to be you guys I hope I hope you
guys get good rest so that's it for me
man faith